in the last episode we went over the main secrets in the DLC and
As I'm sure you noticed it's so easy to think you found everything, but there's always more secrets tucked away
For example until very recently I did not know Midir had a grab attack
When I first beat Midir it was with a silver knight leader cosplay and in the five hours it took to deplete Midir's
Gigantic health pool, I remember continuously thinking "Man
Ledo could have looked so much better" because a few days before release
hundreds of assets were data mined from the Ring City patch and
Amongst these were the Ui icons for a certain armour set look closely at it
So it's a well worn silver knight set and it has a few extra
Modifications to set it apart from the other standard sets of the legion just look at those horns
It would have been so perfect for ledo because he's described as an eccentric
Silver Knight a man wearing well-worn armor from his distant travels around the outskirts of the world
Another thing that didn't make it in are a few more lines of dialogue from the locust preacher
This creature gives exposition on many characters of Dark Souls 3 and if my source is correct
he was supposed to also say "Of all the fingers he alone was embraced by the Abyss, for
he was human and never a grub, fear not the dark my friend and let the feast again
So he's describing a finger of Rosaria, but which one
For a little bit of background fingers of Rosaria our red phantoms who invade kill and pillage
For their own benefit and to gather tongues for their mistress in return they can be reborn
Though those who are reborn one too many times run the risk of turning into grubs
something that does happen to Yellow Finger Hazel in fact "Of all the fingers, he alone was embraced by the Abyss,
For he was human and never a grub" so place your bets who do you think this is describing? There are only really three
options for there are only three male fingers of Rosaria: Creighton the Wanderer, Ring finger Leonard and
Middle Finger Kirk
Personally I think it's Leonard in this dialogue
He was the one who eventually stole Rosaria's soul in some misguided effort to keep it safe
I believe he's the finger in question because the dialogue says he was human and never a grub and
Leonard is described multiple times as rejecting rebirth and the restoration of his scarred Flesh
therefore unlike the other fingers he would never risk turning into a grub and losing his humanity
of course for whatever reason this dialogue was removed which makes it unwise to draw conclusions, but it is interesting nonetheless
For what does it mean to be embraced by the abyss that's something we'll go into in our locust video
I promised so keep an eye for that
Speaking of locusts. Have you ever tried to listen to the locusts below the swamp they say a variation...
and
While I was straining my ears listening for this fairly pointless dialogue, so I could fill out my 20 questions
I noticed that the abdomen of the locusts is
Remarkably similar to that of the angels look at the Iridescent wings and the stinger in particular
Are these reused assets or is there some parallel to be drawn between the two creatures?
Or am I trying really hard to make this a valid point to include in the video who knows?
Just above the locusts is Lapp in what can potentially be the last place you meet him -
"Please someone tell me who am I?"
Why am I here?
Keep revisiting him here and after reloading the game three times
We get solid proof that Lapp was not lying about forgetting his name
And he was not lying about going hollow if you make him hostile here
You can unlock a more satisfying ending to Lapp's story
The Lapp Arc of Patches Quest line is really well executed
and you have to love the clues they give you from the signature squat the slightly tuned voice and
Especially the part where he risks his life to find you treasure if you failed to pick it up
But did you know that it was always possible to guess who Lapp was?
simply from his name
a Lappe is a word in Middle high German
that is used to describe a simple-Minded person or
It's ironically used to call a smart person a fool and obviously this suit Lapp to an insane
Degree because he's both lost his mind
And it's ironic that of all the intelligent people to lose their minds it would be our best friend Patches
furthermore in Middle High German the name Lapp
Also refers to a mender of clothes or shoes and was used to describe a cloth a rag or a patch
Lapp also means patch in Swedish
Anyway after you've talked to Lapp about the ring City. You can track this information back to its source
Why where did you hear name love? Oh, it doesn't matter. I'll tell you what I know
The Rings City is said to be at world's end
Past this heap of rubbish as far as one can go
But you better think twice
the Forsaken Ring City was walled off by the gods to contain the pygmies and
The Dark Soul is better left well alone
Number eight have you noticed what I'm zooming towards
These parts of the dreg heap are on an endless trip
Downwards and you have to wonder are they meant to provide the illusion from a distance that the dreg heap is
collapsing downwards and inwards or was this just an asset that they forgot to lock in place and
Some dreg heap assets should feature more prominently in my opinion
For example if you look left at the very edge of the drop down to the Demon prince you can see the entire undead settlement
cobbled together here and
further down in the Demon Prince Arena
there's the rubble of the first firelink shrine you can even find the well and the stones Dead circle at the center and
Of course don't forget this part of the Grand archives
This rooftop you can jump to in early Lothric
This room where you first encounter Lothric knights, the courtyard in Lothric with two enormous snakes
wait what
I had this tweeted at me by @BestSiegmeyer on Twitter who discovered these giant ash coated snakes
That bleed he posits that they might be primordial serpents
But if they are they certainly lack the familiar features the signature nose the teeth the moustache thing
No, whatever these are I'm not sure they're from any age
We know of, note however that they are impaled with the weapons of the Lothric knights as if a battle took place here
Number 11 with every major drop in the dreg heap
there's the ghost of Gael to guide you but, did you notice also he's ripped off a part of his red cloak and
Weighed it down with a stone these additional markers show you where to go I bet
He regrets it now that cloak probably could have done with the extra range in the boss fight
The most significant piece of red cloth is located in the shared grave of the ring City
Signifying the drops downwards that's necessary to progress you upwards
Speaking of does Patches really screw you over with his final kick
Or is this him trying to help you and while we're on the topic of Red cloth
Yeah, I know it's not really in the Ring City, but it was added with the Ring City patch
Ornsteins plume, thanks to a small change.org petition
Was added and it might have been a simpler task
Because there was an edition of the Dragon Slayer armor which also had a similar plume and similar cloth physics
Another thing added with the patch was these humanity sprite icons which signifies which bonfire location is the most active
So whether it's for PVP or for co-op use these to your advantage. Number 14
one area you can't access despite it being plastered everywhere as
promotional material is this lonely tower just past the first judicator giant
and if you get the judicator giant to throw you over there
You discover
That there's nothing inside
Interestingly enough though there are these statues that you found around
Irithyll though who they're of has always been a bit of a mystery and given that they're meant to be out of eyeshot
I doubt this is much more than a reused asset and never meant to be seen up close
and my God were some things not meant to be seen up close
In the world brought to ruin by the breaking of the shell are two crumbled kingdoms off in the distance
One is Lothric 100% is even a 3D model
You can get close to and look at properly
But further in a blurry 2d asset at the edge of the end of the world is this structure?
It has elements of Anor Londo it has elements of that old Drangleic footage
we saw
but whichever it is
I think that they're trying to convey that this place at the end of the world contains the ruins of the most significant kingdoms and
Lothric being featured so prominently here leads me to believe that our
Unkindled Adventure© was
potentially the most significant of all, as an aside this place at the end is what you saw in the opening cutscene
With a pilgrim come to die outside the ruins of Lothric
"the fire fades"
"and the lord's go without thrones"
and of course the lords of cinder weren't the only ones to Abandon their thrones
so too would the pygmy lords one of whom Crawls towards Filianore
this dude is dedicated look at his skull
its disconnected entirely from his spine. I decided to devote about
67 gigabytes of file space to record this guy's Journey all for this incredible payoff
run death.exe
I'm sure a bunch of you guys did this too. It's the end of the game you have to drag it out somehow
Number 17 the big question is what exactly does Filianore's egg represent and how
Exactly does it add obscure the pygmy [lords] and the dark soul and this end of the world scene
And it's fairly well established that wherever this is it's in the future for example
Gael's weaponry is incredibly worned the pygmy lords have heard rumors of a red hood
Coming to Devour them and of course the entire world has fallen to ash, and I'm still working on my theories
but right now, I believe
Maybe the time passed naturally for everyone else except us
With their world slowly grinding down to ash, but for us
It seems like we were fast forwarded to more or less the exact moment Filianore would eventually die
For a pygmy is crawling to her somehow still expecting her to be alive
I'm getting off topic. Sorry. I'm just really keen to make the main story video for this place
But what I wanted to bring up for at this point was that there's this obscure animated film by Tokuma shoten
called Angels egg and without a doubt
Miyazaki was inspired by this film when creating Filianore's design
And I hoped to watch it and discover the meaning of the egg through this film
We're actually going to have a movie night where we stream and watch the movie together
Over on my discord so check out the description for that
Another theory I've seen about the egg has been thrown around ever since
Filianore's design was shown and it talks about the resemblance between
Filianore's egg and the vagrants of Dark Souls 1 and have to agree. Then is a resemblance
Look at them. They're cracked in much the same way with a coarse dark interior and
Remember these creatures were only present in Dark Souls 1 which was during the close of the age of the gods
So even from a timeline point of view it makes sense that Filianore who was likely placed here in the age of the gods
May have possessed one of the last vagrants
these mysterious creatures
Used to appear in other people's worlds if you dropped items or if you lost a large amount of humanity in your own world
and very very interestingly the cracked vagrants simply drop humanity and Twin humanity
Suggesting that the humanity fragments of the dark soul might have made up that dark interior
And for an egg with a black inside that obscures the dark soul of humanity from those who would claim it
this feels very significant
Speaking of time passing after you've used the Envoy Banner to arrive in the Ringed City
Time passes in Ariandel
And the fire that you lit to eventually engulf Ariandel
takes root in the Chapel
But that's not the only visual change in the outside world because as noticed by xaonzen reddit
There are now more trees in Farron keep
Did they really need more trees here? I didn't realize I mean it looks a bit nicer, but why?
this baffles me if they decided to devote development time to this then what else in the outside world has changed
Well one thing has the epilogue of dark souls 3 the song played in the credits after you beat the Soul of Cinder
Has changed it's become a little bit more powerful and with a few more
instrumentals
I'm going to just let this play for a little while so we can let the end of souls sink in a little bit
I'll see you next time in our story explanation of the Ring City
Also, thank you to the ton of new Patrons we got in the last video this video would have gone out earlier for you guys
But as you can probably tell I got really really sick
And I didn't even think I could narrate and hopefully my voice doesn't sound terrible it probably does
I'm going to listen back to it now. I'll see in the next one. Thanks for watching goodbye
captions done 1/1/18 2:19 pm by jimbo slice